وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجمات بطائرات
مسيره اوكرانيه فوق منطقه ريتولا وبيلكنود
دون وقوع اضرار او خسائر بشريه في المقابل
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
حققت تقدما في الجبهه الجنوبيه وانها
تواصل عمليات الهجوميه باتجاه مدينه
ميليتوبول في مقاطعه
اوكرانيا
المزيد من كافي ينضم الينا مراسلنا عامر
لافي ومن موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين يرحب
بكما بدايه معك عامر اذا واخر التطورات
بعين اوكرانيه
نعم سفيان سابدا من حيث المدنيين الذين هم
دائما ربما من اكثر المتضررين من هذه
الحرب في مناطق الجبهه المدن القريبه على
نقاط التماس المباشر بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه وتحديدا في
اليوم قتل خمس مدنيين واصيب اربعه في قصف
متفرق لهذه المدن في هذه المقاطعه التي
يعني هي اهم وربما تشهد اعنف المعارك ايضا
قبل قليل وصلنا خبر من كوبيانس هذه البلده
التي تقع في تابعه لمقاطعه خار كيف في
اقصى شرق شركيف عند حدود اقليم دومباس قبل
قليل ايضا اعلن حاكم هذه المدينه عن مقتل
شخص وهو حارس لمصنع صغير للحوم قصف هذا
المصنع واصلا هو لا يعمل هذا المصنع على
اعتبار ان هذه المدينه كوبيانس هي من
المدن التي تشهد يعني اشد انواع القصف منذ
فتره في لان القوات الروسيه تحاول منذ
فتره السيطره عليه وربما هذا المحور
هو المحور الوحيد الذي تقوم فيه القوات
الروسيه بالهجوم ومحاوله للتقدم على العكس
من بقيه المحاور حيث تحاول القوات الروسيه
الدفاع في مقابل الهجوم والهجوم المضاد
الذي اعلنت عنه اوكرانيا قبل كما تعلم قبل
شهرين ونصف ربما بالتصريحات السياسيه ايضا
المتعلقه بالجبهه لابد من ذكر تصريح المهم
واللافت اليوم لميخائيل بوليليات المستشار
في مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي والذي
تحدث عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه تستطيع
الوصول وتدمير اي هدف في شبه جزيره القرم
وهذا كان عباره عن انه يريد ان يقول بان
ضوء ان اخبرا من حلفائهم الغربيين
الاستهداف هذه المنطقه التي كان هناك تحفظ
على استهدافها تعلم
الشركاء الغربيين لكيف كانوا يمنعون
استهداف العمق الروسي وكان هناك تحفظ على
شبه جزيره القرم مع انها تعتبر ارض محتله
احتلت في عام 2014
واضح ان هذا التحفظ قد رفع الان والقصف
مستمر من اوكرانيا على مناطق مختلفه سواء
بالمسيرات
والسيارات الجويه والمسيرات البحريه وايضا
مؤخرا بالصواريخ حيث اعلنت كياف انها طورت
صاروخ استطاع ان يضرب مجمع لانظمه اس 400
في شبه جزيره القرم اللافت هنا والمهم ان
الاوكرانيين يتحدثون عن ان كل هذه الاسلحه
هي اسلحه اوكرانيه مصنعه محليا وبالتالي
لا يحق لاحد ان يسال اوكرانيا اوكرانيا
اين ستستخدم هذه الاسلحه وهذا طبعا بدا
يندرج ليس فقط على شبه جزيره القرم وانما
ايضا على الداخل الروسي بالنسبه ايضا
للتصريحات المهمه على الجبهات يبقى
التباين في التصريحات طبعا نتحدث عن
تقدمهم في منطقه ما فيتحدث الاوكرانيين عن
تقدمهم في نفس المنطقه على سبيل المثال
اليوم المتحدث باسم قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه تحدث عن تقدم في زبروجا مع ان
القوات الروسيه قالت
انها تمكنت من اخراج القوات الاوكرانيه
منها وعن تقدم ايضا في منطقه مخمود في
النستمع لما قال
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هجومها في
اتجاهات ميلوتوبول وباخموت وحققت قوتنا
نجاحا في اتجاهات
ويتم تحسين المقاتلين الاوكرانيين على
الحدود التي وصلوا اليها وفي اتجاه بخموت
تواصل قوات الدفاع القيام بعمليه هجوميه
جنوب مدينه
هجوميه فاشله في منطقه
ويستمر القتال العنيف هناك
ابقى معنا عامر اذهب الى امين برغامي في
موسكو اذا الروس ما الذي يقولون بشان اخر
المستجدات
سفيان يمكن تقسيم تطورات اليوم في روسيا
الى ميدانيه واخرى عبر تصريحات سياسيه
ميدانيا طبعا وزاره الدفاع تحدثت اليوم عن
اكثر من اعتراض للمسيرات والصواريخ
القادمه من اوكرانيا سواء فوق مياه البحر
الاسود او في مقاطعتي وايضا بريانسك اضافه
الى انها تحدثت طبعا عن الاعتراض صاروخ من
طراز نيبتون المضاد للسفن لم تحدد موقع
هذا الاعتراض وذلك لاول مره منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب ونعلم ان اوكرانيا كانت العمل
الماضي قد استهدفت سفينه روسيه عسكريه وهي
فرقه موسكو في البحر الاسود باستخدام هذا
النوع من الصواريخ طبعا قبل قليل فقط
في تطور لربما سيتبعه ما يتبعه كان حاكم
مقاطعه بريانس قد اعلن عن مقتل عدد من
المدنيين في قصف اوكراني بصواري على بلده
حدوديه في مقاطعه بريانس كدون ان يحدد عدد
القتلى والجرحى بتحديد وقال بان هيئات
الطوارئ الان تعمل على كشف او تحديد عدد
الضحايا وايضا ملابسات هذا الهجوم سياسيه
طبعا اليوم كانت كان هناك تصريحان في
الحقيقه التصريح الاول
لنائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الذي علق على تصريحات مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخايلو بودولياك حينما قال
بان اوكرانيا طبعا واذا ما صح قول بودياك
بشان تلقي كييف الضوء الاخضر من الشركاء
الغربيين لاستهداف العمق الروسي قال بان
هذا تطور خطير وبانه يضع او يعطي اطرا
قانونيه لروسيا من اجل شني حرب على دول
النيتو والدول الغربيه واعتبر بان هذا
الامر يقرب ما وصفه بنهايه العالم بعد ذلك
طبعا كان هناك تصريح للمتحدث باسم
الكرمليد متريبي ايضا تعليقا على تصريحات
بودولياء قال بان اوكرانيا الان تبدو كل
جهودها من اجل
جره الغرب الى مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا الى
ابعد الحدود وقلب ان الغرب يدرك
المخاطر الحتميه وايضا التكاليف الحتميه
بحسب غوصه وصفه لاي صدام مباشر بين روسيا
ودول الناتو طبعا هذه التصريحات كما سبق
وقلت جاءت ردا على تصريحات بدولياك روسيا
ترى بان توالي الهجمات الروسيه على شبه
جزيره القرم وهي التي تعتبرها جزء لا
يتجزا من اراضيها اذا ما تم استخدامها
بصواريخ او اسلحه
غربيه الصنع فان ذلك يعد مشاركه مباشره من
قبل تلك الدول في الحرب وبالتالي
تعود موسكو الى ما كانت في بدايه هذه
الحرب تشدد عليها وتسميه طبعا الخطوط
الحمراء وبانه اذا ما تم تجاوزها فان
روسيا ستبقي لها الحق في ان تشن حربا على
الدول الغربيه وتحذر طبعا من تبعات اي
صدام او مواجهه مباشره مع دول الناتو شكرا
لك من درغام كنت معنا من موسكو والشكر
موصول لعامر لافي الذي كان ايضا معنا من